The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's
go ahead and start
Lecture 6, which is
all about strategy.
And we're going to try
to be numerical about it
because numbers
make us feel smart.
So strategy is a nebulous thing.
It can't be easily defined,
and very many people
spend all day talking
about it without giving
any statistics or
numerical results.
Which I think is quite a
shame because, especially
in this Battlecode,
we can actually
do computations and say, OK,
if I build this many of x,
I can build this many of y.
And we can get to some
pretty interesting results.
I'm going to start out by
just having a seat here,
and I'm going to talk about
some sort of general stuff.
And then we'll move straight
into numerical strategy, which
I've got here on the
right of the view screen.
And you can see, like,
I've implemented Battlecode
in Mathematica to
a limited extent
for the express purpose of
showing graphs like these.
So we'll get to those.
Let's talk about
Battlecode a little bit.
The way I see it
is that strategy
can be expressed as having
a triangle aspect to it
because you're basically
picking between a technology
route, an econ route,
and a military route.
And then among military, I like
to try to draw another line.
And you can sort of imagine this
triangle as being on a plane.
This is on a plane that's like
perpendicular to this line,
indicating that you can
sort of be in any of them.
I could have drawn it
as a triangular prism,
but I chose not to.
So then this
triangle, you can have
a defensive military
strategy, or you
can have an offensive one.
Offensive is spelled that way.
And I also like to populate
this map with even more things
to make it less clear
what's going on.
So I'm going to put
over here large map,
and I'm going to put
over down here small map.
Because if you're
on a small map,
you want to have more
military, at least early on.
I mean, this is
all time-changing.
So you could describe a
strategy in time as being like,
OK, first, I'm going to
do a lot of military,
and then I'm going
to get some econ,
and then I'm going to get tech.
So like that's a strategy,
though it looks pretty weird.
That looks pretty weird, and
it's crossing out my small map.
Anyway, so small
map, it is really
another way of saying
it's far to the enemy base
or it's close.
So on a small map, you can
get right to the enemy base.
You got to be prepared if
they've got a rush strategy.
Maybe what you ought to
do instead of saying,
OK, I'm going to use
the map size, is do
sort of a heuristic.
Because you could
imagine this map--
I'm going to do
example maps here--
and this map
currently identical.
Now let's make them different.
This one's got
like tons of mines,
and this one has a
little bit of mines.
Obviously, they're different.
I mean, if the headquarters
are here and here in these two
maps, well, this one is
effectively a small map,
and this one is
effectively a large map.
So here's a suggestion.
It's not very expensive to
sense mines at location.
It costs 10 in the
MethodCosts.txt file.
So you could consider
saying, all right,
I'm this headquarters.
For the first couple
of rounds, I'm
going to compute the sum of
the number of mines between me
and the enemy in sort of a
volume looking like that.
And so I'm just going
to compute this number,
just going to total it all up.
If the map is, say, 50 by
50, then how many tiles
do you need to count?
Well, say you make it 4
wide, just for halibut.
And then down in
this direction, I
guess it would end up
being sort of like 50.
So you'd have about 200
tiles to look at times 10.
That's going to be 10
bytecodes per sense tile,
and so you've only got 2,000.
You can do that
easily in one turn
because the bytecode
limit is 10,000.
So then you could very
quickly get an estimate
of how easy or difficult
it is to get to your enemy
right off there.
And so then you
could find your spot,
say, OK, I'm here or
here on my Tech Tree.
The system doesn't have to
be incredibly complicated.
So let's delete
some of this mess
that I've made
here so that I can
make some notes
about the differences
between defensive and
offensive strategy.
Later on, we're going to
see the number of units
that you can get if you're
pushing for an early advantage,
and that's going to
sort of tie into this.
So there's a time
aspect, where you're
saying, if you're defending,
you have a number of advantages.
One is that you can have
additional units up at the time
when the enemy arrives.
Another is that the
pathing is much easier
because you don't
have to go anywhere.
You can establish a
better concave in theory
because the enemy might
have to defuse mines.
It's worth noting
here that, of course,
you're not guaranteed
this advantage
because the enemy
knows where you are.
You're sort of around
your headquarters.
I mean, it's generally true that
if you can recognize the enemy
is around his headquarters,
so he's all sort of
clumped up here.
Well, it's pretty easy
for you to say, all right,
I'm going to stay at a
distance r from that enemy,
and I'm just going to
sort of group up there.
And as soon as everybody is
within a distance r and not
farther than a distance
this other letter,
then I know that I'm in a good
position to attack all at once.
And so if the enemy's just sort
of hiding there in its hole,
then that's also a vulnerability
as well as an advantage.
So you could imagine that case.
And you could also
imagine the case
where there's a ton of mines,
and so the minefield is
like this giant, thick
thing, which is filled.
And so you're
defending over here.
And yeah, you're defending here,
and the enemy's coming at you.
And they kind of
have to go in a line
because it's such
a big mine field,
so you can just
sort surround them.
Yeah, I meant to do that
outlining on purpose.
Oh, my goodness.
Who can use Microsoft Paint?
I certainly can.
Let's see here.
So yeah, there's
this concave issue.
And then there's
another issue that you
can have the base take hits.
So your base has 500 hit points.
So you can use that
as a sort of buffer
to try to protect your robot.
It's a very good idea,
but it would spread out
the damage a little bit.
So in the event of
an emergency, it
could be superior to being
farther from your base.
Also consider that it's
easier to heal your robots
because you're going to have
this area sort of established.
You're going to know
where things are.
You're going to have a safe
path to the nearest medbay
that you might build.
And later on we're going to
look at the effects of building
medbay versus other things.
It's going to be really good.
So these are just sort of
a first look at things.
There's some other
stuff in here,
like about tactical withdrawal.
When do you realize that
everything's gone to shit,
and you've got to back out?
What's the value of preserving
your units versus the penalty
of having them not in combat?
They're in transit
between wherever they are
and the medical bays
that you've built.
Because you could easily
imagine filling the whole
map with medical bays just
to reduce that transit time.
And would that be worth
it compared to just not
having them go to medbay
or only engaging in battles
within a certain
range of the medbay?
So you might actually
be retreating to a range
rather than directly
to the thing itself.
These are things
that you'll probably
end up thinking about
if you haven't already.
Let's jump straight
into some simulations.
So what I've done
in this model--
let me zoom in just
a little bit-- is
I've got a system where
you can build bots.
Bots will die if you have
less than zero resources.
You can build generators,
as you can see here.
I mean, I'm not expecting
you to read this.
But just showing you the
parts that are in the model
so that when you look
at the model results,
you can see for yourself whether
you think they're realistic.
So you can build generators.
And as in the game,
the generators
will provide you an additional
10 resources per turn.
And the cost of
building a generator
is 20 times the
number of encampments
that are currently built.
And here's plus 1 for
the additional one
that you're building.
Same thing applies
for suppliers.
It's got the same build cost.
But instead, it's advantage
is that the spawn time then
becomes this number.
Note that this is different
from what it was in Lecture 1.
In Lecture 1, the spawn
time was 10-- it was this.
It was 10 times 0.95 to the
power of supplier number,
where supplier number is the
number of suppliers you have.
That's what it used to be.
But it's been switched
to this number
in order to make it slightly
worse, because it was too good.
This and the other changes have
been updated on the Battlecode
data sheet that I
made that you might
remember from the website.
So if you're using that,
make sure that you've
updated recently.
And when you download
it, hit F5 or Refresh,
because it has the same
file name as before.
So your computer might
not download it again
unless you specifically
tell it to.
That's just something
to worry about.
Because it's terrible to be
on a bad version of the specs
because then you
think I'm wrong,
and that's just very, very
hard to handle for me.
So here's your spawn time here.
So that's what your
suppliers are doing for you.
And so I've made this model that
tries to build these things,
tries to build robots, and
it kills the excess ones.
So we're trying to reach
a large number of robots.
to Zoom out just
a little bit here.
So you can see here that
we've got power over time,
and this is for 500 rounds.
I've got it so
that you can change
the length of the simulation.
And we're going to see quite
a number of simulations
here today.
So you could see here
that, at first, you
start out with no power.
I don't know if this is 100%
realistic because I think
in the game you might actually
start out with full power
to begin with.
But that's a transient effect.
I wouldn't really
worry about it.
We're physicists here.
We talk about
orders of magnitude.
Yes.
So you could see here that
initially your power decays
upward to some
relatively stable value.
But it begins to decrease
as you build robots,
because as the number of
robots increases over time,
the upkeep is increasing.
And so you're decaying downward
to stable values as you go.
And then it becomes a
stable number of robots
as they are produced, and then
they also run out of energy.
So I've also plotted down
here the maximum number
of robots that are achieved
within a simulation.
So this shows that you hit
40 robots at round 391.
We're going to end up
looking at this quantity
and trying to see how
we can make the most
robots at the
shortest round number.
Or how we can have a trade-off
between maybe getting
the most robots
at an early number
or getting more robots
at a later number, which
would embody the
difference between a rush
strategy and an econ strategy.
I've also plotted
the spawn time so
that you can see how
the effect of suppliers
is changing how long it
takes for robots to spawn.
In this example, there
aren't any suppliers,
so the spawn time is flat.
So let's change the
example a little bit.
I'm going to zoom
out just a tiny bit,
making everything illegible,
so that you can see also
the inputs to this
function that I've made.
And so I'm going to make it
so that the bytecode usage is
5,000.
And what effect
should that have?
It should decrease the number
of robots that we can sustain.
And sure enough, we see
that when we run it,
the maximum number we hit is
now 27 robots at round 261.
So we've hit there sooner,
but it's a smaller number.
It's just worse in every way.
You want to save bytecodes.
So let's go back
to that example.
Now, generator built
rounds and supplier
built rounds is the number of
rounds between every time it
will attempt to build a
generator or a supplier.
This is the basic version
that I started with.
So let's start by building
generators every 10 rounds.
This is assuming that there
are enough generators around
for us to build on.
So you can see here that the
first generator is built around
here.
There's a tiny dip, and
here's another and another.
But the generator
doesn't actually
kick in and start to take
effect until 50 turns later
because there's a capture delay,
and it doesn't do anything
while it's being captured.
Then once these are
captured, the amount of power
you have skyrockets.
So this was the
previous maximum of 200.
And now we're up to 2,000
power in just 500 rounds.
This shows that you can really
amplify your economy rapidly.
You'll notice here that
the sawtooth behavior
is becoming increasingly severe.
This is because each
one of these motions
downward indicates the purchase
of yet another generator, which
costs more than the last.
Because as I mentioned
before, the cost
of capturing an encampment is 20
times the number of encampments
you have already.
So that's going to
linearly increase.
You could see that it's
recovering faster and faster
though because, as
has been mentioned,
the generators do produce
10 energy per turn.
So here we can see that
it's not hitting any limit
to the number of robots
that can be built.
And if we extend the
simulation out to 2,000 rounds,
we can see that it just
continues on as it was before,
and the number of
robots is unlimited.
So if you do find a map that
has a whole lot of encampments
to capture-- and we
haven't specified
that there's a maximum
number of encampments
as far as I know--
then you could end up
just continuing to
build these things.
And then it doesn't matter
how terrible your micro is
or how terrible your tech
is because you'll just
overwhelm the enemy.
Hey, look, at round
1991, what a good year.
That's pretty special.
So let's go back
down to 500 where
we can see what's going on,
and let's change generator
built rounds to 1.
So now we're going to try to
build a generator every round.
But look at here.
These red dots indicating
the completion of generators
are non-uniformly spaced.
That seems to
indicate that it's not
able to build
generators every turn.
That's because there's
not enough power.
You can see here that the
power is as close to 0
as it possibly can
without destroying robots
from bringing it down
to negative values.
So you can see here
that you can now
get to have more robots than
you otherwise would have.
No, that's not true.
You can't have any more
robots because we're still
limited by the rate at which
they're being produced.
They're only being produced
one every 10 rounds,
and that's really cramping
our style, as it were.
So let's increase this
back up to a million
so that it's not building
any more generators.
Let's try building
just suppliers.
So let's build a
supplier every 10 rounds.
As you can see here,
here's the money
being expended on suppliers.
And pretty soon, even
before round 100,
we start hitting a point where
the number of robots we have,
which is accelerating over
time as the spawn time
is decreasing, the
number of robots going up
is preventing us from
getting enough power
to continue building suppliers.
So we're actually capped.
This behavior, where the
power goes down and crashes,
is going to really hurt our
ability to play the game.
It becomes exacerbated the
faster you build suppliers.
Because you see here, I built
these suppliers, and then,
bingo.
I've only built a total
of-- let's see here,
supplier number, I've built
a total of eight suppliers
within the first, I don't
know, this looks like 40 turns.
And now I'm not going
to be able to build
anything else for
the whole game,
because the next encampment
that I buy would cost 8 times 20
is 160, plus 20 for the next
one, is going to be 180.
I simply can't afford
that if my power is never
exceeding 170 over here.
So that's pretty much going
to be a crippling blow.
So maybe, as my player, I
need to do one of two things.
One, maybe I should build
suppliers and generators.
Two, I could notice that
maybe the enemy has killed
a bunch of my generators, but I
still have suppliers left over.
Have you thought about that?
Maybe some of your
suppliers will
have to destroy
themselves to make room
for more power generation.
It could be something that
happens to you less than not
ever, or which is to say
more often than not ever.
So let's make it 10 and 10.
So we're trying to
do some of each.
Well, it's not really working.
It's like building some,
and then the others
because one of them is taking
precedence over the first.
Maybe we'll try building these
every 20 and these every 10.
Well, now it's
building some of each.
This is not so bad.
So now we're getting
to 76 robots at 496.
Our power is going up,
but we're not so much
wasting it as we were before.
And we can see that the spawn
time has gone all the way down
to half.
Now, this does assume
that none of your robots
are being destroyed.
If you're actively
losing robots,
it makes perfect sense
to build only suppliers
because, at that point,
you can clump up your units
and lose them, which
will give you the money
to continue building units.
It's only when you've favored
suppliers and then not attacked
that you're wasting
your effort and time.
So this is something that I
saw in some of the scrimmage
matches that I've
been looking at,
because we devs have access to
all kinds of secret information
about you, including
the performance
of your players in
scrimmage matches.
And so I've been downloading
these maps and looking at them.
And in these
matches, I've tended
to see that, a lot
of times, we're
favoring suppliers
but not attacking.
Other times, we're
favoring suppliers,
and we're just sending
our units one by one
to be killed by the enemy blob.
I think that's also sub-optimal.
But at the same
time, we have seen
quite a few good strategies.
I've seen some great
pathing, and I've
seen some great
solving for the map.
I think that there's a
lot to be done there.
And I have confidence
that we're going
to see a lot of great matches
in the sprint tournament.
So let's go back to the
model here and look again
at maybe getting a build order.
So here, the build
order I'm defining as,
what order do you get
suppliers and generators?
This way of doing it, as you
see I've implemented it here,
is kind of inefficient,
because whichever
one goes first is
just whichever one
hit the round
counter or something.
So here I re-implement the
whole system with an explicit
build order.
So I can say, all right,
please give me a bunch of 2,
and then give me 2 and then
1 in alternating turns.
So you can see here-- it's
not working very well--
2 is my number for
the supplier, and 1
is my indicator
for the generator.
So here we do five 2's, and then
we alternate 2 and 1 forever.
So there are the five 2's, and
then we've got a 2, 1, and a 2,
and a 1.
Well, that's not very good
because we still crash,
and we only hit a
maximum of 57 robots.
So let's consider reducing
this number of 2's.
Well, that's much better.
So now we've gotten up
to 87 robots around 495.
Now, if you've
been keeping track
in your mind of which
number of robots
we've hit at which
round, congratulations.
You're much better
at that than me.
Later on, I'm going
to be showing plots
so that we don't have to
memorize how many robots we
have at what round.
But for the sake
of illustration,
it's pretty useful to be
able to say, all right, if I
add one more supplier here,
how does that help me?
Well, if you look
very carefully,
it's going to shift your
early number of robots up,
and it's probably going to
shift your late number of robots
down.
That's the way it's
changing the shape.
So you can see here that
that's a very subtle change.
Let's change it so that we're
only building suppliers,
and then we're only
building generators.
So there we've built a
few suppliers, and then
a lot of generators.
That's 62 robots.
We can keep changing it and try.
Here's a few more suppliers.
Well, look at that.
We never got the chance to
build any generators because we
ran out of energy when we
were building suppliers.
This is the same issue
that we were seeing before.
So let's explore the
space automatically.
This is kind of weird.
What I'm going to
show you is a plot
of the peak number
of robots that you've
gotten during the simulation
versus the number of rounds.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to sort of move along the
space in some line, which
is going to be an automatic
search for these various things
that we're looking for.
So yeah, so where do you
want to be on this graph?
You want to be up
here at the upper left
because that means that
you're getting a lot of robots
at a small number of rounds.
This is the phenomenon
that we were seeing before,
where going from
1, 2, 3, 5, 7, 8--
you could see that it's skipping
some numbers because they would
have written over one another.
Yeah, I'll show it
with all the numbers.
Well, that's odd.
It changed shape.
Ba, ba da, ba, ba,
ba, ba, ba, ba.
Well, let's go with it.
So this example is-- did I
define the explicit system?
This is the explicit
system here.
Did I set that?
And then did I define it?
Well, all right,
that's how it is.
So this system is showing
you from 0 up to 15
for every time it's
trying a longer
or a shorter system of
building the suppliers.
So if it says 0,
it means it just
goes straight into generators.
And if it says a
higher number, then it
has built that many suppliers
before it goes into generators.
So you could see,
yeah, so that's there.
And the numbers sort of
start to overlap one another,
so I made this little function
that gets rid of the numbers
if they're too close
to another number.
And that changed the way
it looked quite a bit.
[INAUDIBLE] 2,000 at the bottom
if you take that [INAUDIBLE]?
I see, I see.
It was going out to 2,000.
Thank you, thank you.
So let's make this, yeah,
let's make this just to 1,000.
Strategy exploration is there.
Simplified exploration is here.
Yeah.
So there are the numbers.
And this phenomenon is the thing
that we've been seeing before,
that as you have more and
more suppliers to begin with,
it's OK up to a
point, at which you
can't build any more robots.
And you hit a limit because
you've run out of power.
OK.
That's what we've
seen, seen it 100 ways.
That's good.
Let's switch to a mix of things.
So instead of doing
all one, we do a mix
so that we're alternating
one and the other.
So in this example,
we're starting
with i numbers of
suppliers, and then we're
going to follow it
up with alternating
generators and suppliers.
And you can see
here that the best
result seems to be something.
I mean, you really
can't decide just
based on this graph because
these are maximum points.
And if this is 8,
is that a better way
to operate for a rush strategy?
Well, here's a way of
addressing that question.
Here I've plotted
the number of robots
versus the round for this 0.
And you can see here
that it's always
above the other
peak robot counts.
So that indicates that
it's definitively better
to start building generators
before you start building
suppliers, at least if you're
aiming for the peak robot
condition.
You're trying to get the
greatest number of robots.
So there you go.
It's better always to use zero.
And here if we compare
different strategies,
we can see them
on the same space.
And one is obviously better.
This one above here that's new
is much better than the one
we had before.
It gets us more robots
at the same round number.
And again, we're trying
to get to the upper left
of this graph.
This strategy consists
of building a generator,
and then building
a supplier i times.
So we'll do that set i
times, and then we'll
go into building 1, 2, 2.
So then we'll be building
a generator for every two
suppliers.
And we could see that this
is much better at any point.
So that's pretty interesting.
That is pretty interesting.
Because then we
can say, all right,
I've played around with this.
Maybe it's better to have three.
Is that even better?
We'll see, we'll see.
That changes the
shape a little bit.
So that gives me a bit of an
improvement in this region.
So if we really want to have
the most robots at this round,
possibly the best way to
do it is to start here.
And I know that these are
all pretty obscure-looking,
so I'm going to just skip
straight on down to over here,
where we can look at
the effect of a rush.
And we can see it
very concretely
that, in this example, we've
got the first guy in blue.
He's building only
generators for 40 rounds,
and then he's going to
start building suppliers.
So there you can see blue
is building only generators,
and then he starts
building suppliers.
And his robot production
rate increases.
Here in red, the red guy is
starting by building suppliers.
And so you can see he caps out
at 41 suppliers, or 41 robots
for a moment, and then
he's back to oscillating.
So he's got a military advantage
in this window starting
from round 100 going up to
round 300, where, for a time,
he's going to
outnumber the enemy.
And his goal is to
win during this time.
So if you outnumber the
enemy starting at round 100
and going to 300, here's
what you have to do.
You have to get to the enemy
and start shooting at him.
So if the map is
really, really big,
like if the map
is 100, size 100,
you don't have the
pickax upgrade.
So you're going to be defusing
mines at 12 rounds per mine.
If you've got 50 mines
in the way and 12 each,
there's no way that
you're going to get there.
Because it's going to
take you 500 rounds just
to get to the enemy,
and you'll never
actually get to start shooting.
But if you can find a
straight path to your enemy,
even if the map
is 50 units long,
you can get there and start
capitalizing on your unit
advantage before his
econ play kicks in.
So there you go, a
very concrete example
of the effects of rushing
or playing an econ.
At the same time,
you could definitely
imagine intermediate strategies.
So here I'm just going
to go ahead and plot
a third strategy, which
maybe I'll make in green.
And maybe this strategy
is a mix of the two.
So instead of starting with just
generators or just suppliers,
we'll do a combination of
generators and suppliers.
Now look at that.
That's pretty interesting.
Let's extend the simulation
length to 800 rounds,
and we'll be able
to see the effects.
So now we see that the green
player does almost as well
as the red player.
It's almost indistinguishable
at this distance.
And given the
defensive advantage
we talked about earlier, it may
be enough for the green player
to hold off.
He'll still be able to
smash the red player.
And he's still got an
advantage over the blue player
without being that
much at a disadvantage.
That is to say that the
green advantage lasts
until about round 600.
Let's zoom in a little bit
so that we can see round 600
and try to assess how much
better the green player is
than the blue player.
So here, once again,
green is building
alternating generators
and suppliers.
And he has an
advantage over blue
starting at about round 100
and going to about round 450.
That's a pretty big
round and that's
a pretty big advantage
for a pretty long time.
It's only at that time that
blue begins to take off
and gets a serious advantage.
So you can see here that there's
a pretty significant difference
between different
strategies and that you
can achieve a significant
difference of units.
But how many different
differences of units
are important to start
really making a difference?
I mean, if you have 10
units versus their 11,
how good is that?
Is that a lot?
Is it a little?
It doesn't seem like very much.
Well, to answer
that question, I've
made yet another simulation.
Because why not do a simulation?
Simulations are fun.
So here's a look at it.
And what I've made here is
sort of a very basic simulator
that works in the following way.
I'm going to zoom
in a little bit.
So this is some
combat, and I'm going
to simulate the combat
between 10 and 11 units.
I'm going to do it
a couple of times.
I'll start out doing
it slowly, so I'm
decreasing the
compute time here.
So there's 11 units
on the bottom,
and these are their hit points.
And there are 10
units on the top.
I'm going to do it once again.
I'm going to start
with 10 and 10.
This is team A on top
and team B on bottom.
As you can see here,
that when there
are the same number of
units, they all lose
hit points at the same
rate, and they all
die at the same time, at
least in my simulation.
When there's an advantage,
that extra robot that you have
can start dealing additional
damage to his robots.
And so that advantage becomes
more significant over time.
So if we have 100
units versus 101 units,
then we'll be here all day.
But the point is
that you'll end up
seeing a more and
more significant
difference between the two.
That didn't seem to work
quite right, did it?
But perhaps it did.
It may just have the
exact same result.
I'd be quite curious.
Well, in any case,
we're going to go back
to the example we
were showing before.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to say, OK, when you have
10 versus 11, the 11 team
ends up with four units left.
And two of them are very low
hit points, but two of them
have a lot of the
points remaining.
So we can start to define two
quantities, the robot kill
ratio and the HP kill ratio.
So the robot kill ratio is
to say I put in 11 units,
and I got out four
of mine remaining.
So 11 is the bottom.
I got four remaining,
so that cost me seven.
But in the process
of costing me seven,
I was able to take
out 10 enemy units.
So that's 10 divided
by 7, and if we
make it numerical with
a decimal point there,
we see that number.
Question.
Yeah, how [INAUDIBLE]?
So I'm actually
modeling the combat
by distributing
the attack evenly
from one side and the other.
And then any remaining units
will have the opportunity
to deal more damage
to the enemy team.
So I don't know exactly
how accurate it is.
And if you can manage to
maintain a tight choke point,
then you can trade
evenly with your enemy.
But that's the best you can
do if you're outnumbered.
If you have the advantage
and you surround the enemy,
then you could do
even better than this.
This is something like a middle
ground between those two cases.
Good question.
If you want to see the
actual way that it works,
learn Mathematica and read
the code that's right here.
So we see here that there's
the robot kill ratio.
That's pretty good.
We came to the fight with
10% additional units,
and we end up getting 40%
more value out of our units
that we lost.
On a hit point basis, we didn't
get that much of an advantage.
Bringing a 10% advantage got
us 6% hit point advantage
on how many hit points we were
able to lose versus the enemy.
So let's look at
a lot of results.
So here on the left,
I made a table.
So I've just done the simulation
for 20 units versus i units,
where i goes from 21 to 30.
So you can see the force ratio
that I'm bringing to the table.
Here I'm imagining that I
have more than the enemy.
But of course, you can
just invert these numbers
and get the reverse case.
The force ratio I'm bringing is
5% extra, 10% extra, and so on,
and that achieves
these unit kill ratios.
You can see here I've
capped it out at 20,000
so that it doesn't
display the infinity sign.
Because here, once you have more
than 1/3 more than the enemy,
you don't lose any units
at all during combat.
That's according to the
simulation that I've set up.
A pretty amazing
result if you ask me.
So you can see here that the
unit kill ratio magnifies quite
intensely.
The hit point kill ratio
doesn't magnify that intensely.
So here, 5% force ratio gets
you about 20% unit kill.
10% gets you 40%.
15% gets you 80% extra.
And then once you get
up higher, it just
ramps up more from there.
So it shows that even it's
a fight of five versus four,
it's probably a very bad
idea to engage the enemy.
Because you're not going to be
able to kill any of their units
before they kill all of yours,
which means that all of theirs
can sort of head
back to a medbay,
get healed up, and then
be back to the fight.
It's worth mentioning here
that the medbay can end up
being as productive
as your headquarters.
So let's go back up to where
I've talked about the medbay.
Let's talk about it here.
So let's talk about the
production abilities
of your various capabilities.
You've got your
headquarters, which
is making units at
40 hit points each.
And let's say that it produces
them every 10 rounds, or maybe
every 5 rounds at best if
you've got a lot of suppliers.
So this is your
headquarters building units.
So it's building hit
points every turn.
So it's building from four
to eight hit points per turn.
Well, that's not too bad.
That's building four to
eight hit points per turn.
But what about everything else?
A medbay can heal two
hit points for every
of the adjacent units.
So that there, right there--
if you can multiply correctly--
it's 16 hit points per turn.
That's so many.
That's the value of two
headquarters right there,
even considering headquarters
at full supplier capacity.
That just shows that even
if you're using medbays
incorrectly or doing it wrong in
the various ways that you can,
you'll still be doing a much
better job than a headquarters
alone.
I mean, that's ignoring
the fact that there
are other things at play here.
Like you have to
have injured units
in order to produce
hit points in a medbay.
But it's certainly
worth mentioning
that even this basic
analysis shows what it is.
Very clear.
Now, what's the killing
ability of artillery?
It's been said that
they're overpowered.
Or that they're quite strong,
and they're definitely
worth using.
But is the killing power
of an artillery worth
it compared to the
healing power of a medbay?
Purely from a
numerical standpoint,
you can see here that the
best the artillery can do
is to deal 40 damage to
its target and 20 damage
to each of eight targets
adjacent for a total of 200,
if I did that math correctly.
And it does that every 20 turns,
which is its attack delay.
So that gives us 10
hit points per turn.
Look at that.
Oftentimes, 10 less than 16.
True.
It's even going to tell me that.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, what a big surprise.
So you can make the
decision for yourself.
And of course, each
one has its own uses,
because the artillery
is not always
going to be able to
deal 10 hit points.
Medbay's not always going
to be able to heal units.
Maybe it's too far
from the headquarters
to be a real defensive asset.
Maybe not.
There are a lot of
considerations to include.
But doing a
calculation like this
can certainly help you out
in making your decisions.
For example, I mean,
I think it's worth
doing the following check.
Check if there's an
encampment near your base.
If there is, go ahead
and make it a medbay.
If it's not that
near, maybe it's
better to make it artillery.
Like if it's adjacent, you
probably want a medbay.
But if it's not
close, the medbay
becomes less and less valuable.
Whereas if it's in
still artillery range,
maybe it's still worth having.
It's the kind of question-- this
is the kind of trade-off you
could make, and you could
just hard-code it in.
If it's more than a
distance 16, distance
squared 16, then go
ahead, do it this way.
Otherwise, do it that way.
Very simple way of
addressing the problem.
So let's go back down
and let's talk more
about encounters of units.
So let's continue with this
unit kill ratio results table.
So we're here.
And you know, it's kind of
hard to look at numbers.
Oftentimes when people
have a lot of numbers,
especially in a
table, they plot it.
So here I've got a plot.
Doesn't mean that much.
Let's do a list plot
so we've got points.
And so we're asking the
question-- here is the input.
Is that the input?
No, the input, it
goes up to 1.3.
Yeah, the input is here.
So this is having 5% advantage,
10% advantage, and so on.
And the question is,
how many hit points
is that worth for you?
What hit point advantage
does that get you?
And so we could do a best
fit for these results.
So in Mathematica that would
look like-- find a fit.
You put the data in.
You put the
expression ax plus b,
where a and b are
the parameters,
and x is the
variable in question.
And this is your fit
rule, and then you
can just apply that
to the expression.
And in one line--
we'll have a plot.
So we'll plot this
thing, mess that it is.
Well, OK, why don't
we just call it here.
The line is this, so we're
finding the best fit line here.
And x goes from-- I
don't know-- 0 to 1.5,
and that ought to do it for us.
We'll plot that line, and
we'll plot these points.
So we'll call it
points equals that,
and we'll show the line
together with the points.
And we'll also be able
show other things.
PlotStyle Red.
We'll make the line red
because that's real style.
That's real style.
That almost worked.
There you go.
So there's a line.
What line is that?
It's the line where-- the line.
Please tell me the line.
It's 0.69.
So there you go.
The slope here is 0.69.
I mean, of course,
this is probably not
valid down at these low numbers.
But the point is that for
every additional 1% or one unit
that you add, that's going to be
an extra 0.7 units that you're
going to damage of your enemy.
And it's sort of fairly
linear between 1 and 5.
Let's see if we really
dominate the enemy how
the results will
sort of stack up.
So here it's simulating
a whole bunch of combat,
and it's going really slowly.
Why is it going slowly?
Well, because I put in
like that delay thing
so that you could see
what was going on.
So I'm going to
change the delay to 0
and scroll right on back
down, giving everybody
in the room nausea.
There's also a bunch
of print statements.
So we're seeing like 200
print statements, which
was to print the dynamic
results of the match
so that you could see them
fighting, sort of seeing
numbers decrease on a board,
which is a lot like combat
in the eyes of a nerd.
So then we can see here
a bunch of force ratios.
And here in this example,
we see that we're
maxing out at a certain number.
So according to the way that
I've set up this simulation,
beyond a force
ratio of 2, you're
not getting any
additional advantage
out of your additional
troops because they just
can't find a place to stand.
In reality, when you have four
versus one or eight versus one,
there's a place for
all of your eight guys
to stand around all of
their one poor little guy.
But if you have a
large number of units,
it may be less realistic
to assume that there's
that much room available
for them to double
team, or quadruple team, or
eight-tuple team the enemy.
So you could see here that
these are some results.
And now if we plot
them again, we
see that we sort of hit the
ceiling right over here,
and so the line sort
of is totally destroyed
and comes out wrong.
Let's go up to 3 so we
see how bad-looking it is.
And this is just
yet another example
of how doing a best
fit line to something
is not the right answer
100% of the time.
It's the right answer
99.99% of the time.
Or basically use the r squared
number to see if it's-- no,
I'm just kidding.
That's not genuine statistics.
And most of you are
probably poo-pooing the idea
that I even considered for
a moment or a nanosecond
including the two words
in the same sentence.
So that's a sort of
summary of these issues.
Like what force ratio
gets you what unit or hit
point kill ratio?
You can see here a big takeaway
lesson that just 25% more units
or just 30% more
units than the enemy
can make a giant difference.
And you should never engage
when you're outnumbered,
unless you're right
next to the headquarters
and there's no choice.
I strongly recommend
that you consider
the little micro-tricks,
trying to get
your units into the
right place, withdrawing
when it's a good idea.
Remember that if you're
retreating from the enemy
and the enemy is
adjacent to you,
that means you can take
damage every turn while you're
retreating.
So in this game, retreating
is definitely not
encouraged for that reason.
What you need is
like allied units
to sort of distract the enemy
while your injured ones are
going to heal.
Or you need to have your
medbays close enough
that you can
survive the retreat.
Because the way the
game works is, you move,
and then you deal attack damage.
So if you retreat
from your enemy,
you're not adjacent to him
anymore after you've moved.
And then he moves toward
you and deals damage.
And then you retreat, and
you don't deal damage.
And he moves toward
you and deals damage.
And it's just a
very bad situation.
I've been in it myself.
It was very painful to watch.
So with that, I mean,
I think that's going
to be all that I've
got for you today,
even though it's slightly early
on the days I've gone over.
And so I recommend that
you just sort of sit
here, enjoy yourselves,
ask me questions.
And when the Bubble tea
arrives, the deputies
will spring into action.
So thank you very much
for coming to Lecture 6.
I guess I should explain what's
going on in the next lectures.
Next lecture is going to be
an exciting guest lecture,
where we've got one of the
developers of Battlecode
who's been remote and
who was the winner
of Battlecode last year,
fun gamers, on that team.
He's coming here to talk about
various important things.
I forgot what he's--
oh, my goodness.
What a terrible
plug for his talk.
It was going to be about-- no,
that wasn't a helpful comment.
That was just talking.
Yeah, he's going to talk about,
I think, emergent complexity
and like really awesome
tricks that you learn
if you do Battlecode N years,
where N is a large number.